you told Doris Burke that this was for  your dad what do you think your dad  would think about how far you've come  I think it's a question that I ask  myself every single day and I know I  wish you know I had I had the answer and  and I know you know people always  usually tell me that I know he's part of  you and you know I kind of wanted to  hear from his mouth and you know I think  it'll be really cool but for me like I  always say man it's bigger than  basketball and and everything every  night that I go out there I have a  bigger purpose and I play for something  bigger than this basketball and and I  think that's what makes it special  that every night I'm out there you know  no matter the result no matter how many  points are scored you know I'm playing  for something bigger than myself  Thank You pesca